قال زعيم جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين في
اليمن عبد الملك الحوثي ان الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا فشلتا في
عملياتهما التي تستهدف الاعتداء على
الشعوب بعناوين مخادعه واضاف ان
الامريكيين والبريطانيين لا يستطيعون
حمايه سفنهم بما فيها السفن الحربيه التي
تعرضت لهجمات
جماعته كما هو الاسلوب الامريكي الذي
يتبجح بعدوانه على الشعوب ويقدم لنفسه
عناوين مخادعه بهدف ان يحظى ايضا بالتعاون
معه من بقيه الدول
والبلدان ولكنه فشل والحمد لله فشله واضح
وفشل البريطاني واضح معه
ايضا وهم لا يستطيعون ان يحموا حتى سفنهم
حتى القطع الحربيه هي تستهدف
واكد زعيم جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين
استمرارهم في العمليات البحريه طالما
استمر العدوان والحصار على
غزه نحن مستمرون في موقفنا
العسكري على هذا المستوى في العمليات
البحريه وايضا بالاستهداف بكل اشكال
الاستهداف وبكل ما
نستطيع نحن مستمرون وطالما استمر العدوان
والحصار غزه فلن
نتوقف مهما كان الموقف الامريكي وهو لن
يؤثر اصلا على فاعليه
موقفنا